so the object.create technique seems to
be the only one that doesn't have
adverse side effects finally we need to
make the grab method available on all
van instances without making that method
available on any of the car instances
that are not fans as usual we will add
the properties that we want to be
available on all instances of a class to
the prototype object that is stored as a
property on the constructor function and
it seems like we'd be all done but
there's one thing missing
that belongs right here can you think of
anything that we might have undermined
as a result of the fact that we overrode
the prototype object with a brand new
object we created looking at the diagram
for a moment remember that this object
that we placed at the key dot prototype
on our van function replaced an object
that came for free with the van function
so is there anything you can remember
about the original object that was
special and important and might need to
be put back